[Musik]
nico hippe wie geht's okay du hast
gesagt ich habe einen job völlig richtig
aber du hast einfach aufgelegt tut mir
leid die situation in der du angerufen
hast die waren bisher blöd okay gibt es
im job noch
ja was ist das für eine arbeit
es ist ein praktikum am filmset beim
film ja ein team wird hier bald eine
aktuelle serie fürs fernsehen bei der
duh mit arbeiten kannst wirklich ja
wirklich die serie ist ziemlich lustig
und was soll ich da machen
naja du hilfst du kannst du bringst im
team café du passt auf dass kein
fußgänger in die szene läuft solche
sachen klasse ich liebe serien
naja ich schau am liebsten dokumentation
könntest du ich muss den leuten mit
denen ich gesprochen habe noch heute
eine zusage geben sonst ist das angebot
weg also okay
danke ja